bonjour eric revel
bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france eric alors que pensez-vous
de la phrase d'emmanuel macron ça a créé
une nouvelle suspension de séance hier
est ce que ça va faire du bruit selon
vous
bah oui ça va faire du bruit alors moi
enfin moi je la trouve assez paraît
compréhensible à l'éclair puisque c'est
un mot assez fort qui l'ont employé
sévèrement emmerder même si votre
reporter hésité à employer ce terme
alors il ya deux hypothèses pour moi
le président la république s'adressait
aux lecteurs du parisien qui est un
journal en france populaire par
définition alors est ce qu'il a voulu
employer un terme j'allais dire
populaire ce que dans la même interview
ve il emploie le mot emmerder qui est un
mot sinon grossit en tout cas du langage
courant depuis l'envoi aussi le mot vous
avez peut-être vu le mode heureux ils ne
pourront pas ceux qui ne sont pas
vaccinés aller boire un canon alors un
canon c'est aussi du langage populaire
c'est pour dire aller boire un verre
aller boire un verre de vin alors est ce
qu'il a voulu faire populaire le
président de la république ou est ce
qu'il a voulu priver politiquement parce
qu'on sait que 85 90 % des français sont
vaccinés et sont donc plutôt pro vaccin
est donc de cette sorte rentrer en
campagne électorale en fait en choquant
et et en mettant les pieds si j'ose dire
de dents d'or dans la mare bon c'est une
possibilité
cliver et envoyer un démo populaire
maintenant ce qui est sûr quand même
c'est que ça paraît incompréhensible au
sens premier du terme parce que vous en
souvenez sans doute ya quoi il ya il ya
deux semaines trois semaines dans une
longue interview enregistrée pour la
chaîne tf1 le présent le public faisait
au contraire son mea culpa il disait
oui c'est vrai que pendant mon
quinquennat ge et ge et utiliser des
mots qui ont parfois blessés qui ont
parfois choqué en gros je m'en excuse et
patatras quinze jours plus tard il
recommence en employant un mot qui va
choquer et qui va blesser ceux
évidemment qui ne souhaitent pas se
faire vacciner est à mon sens ils n'ont
par exemple mais c'est pas la question
il va choquer ceux qui ne souhaitent pas
se faire vacciner en les traitant
d'emmerdeur alors vous allez me dire
est-ce qu'il a pété les plombs indien
pour reprendre un nombreux public
je ne sais pas en tout cas il a réussi
sans roues d'une certaine manière parce
que ce matin tous les médias va y
compris rtl france ne parle que de ça ne
parle que de ce mot utilisé par le
président de la république française
dans une interview à un grands titres de
la presse quotidienne dôme une certaine
manière pour moi il rentre en campagne
et qu'est ce qu'il fait depuis hier soir
qu'on a eu vent de cette interview en
presse écrite ben ils occupent l'agenda
médiatique il fait qu'on parle de sa
sortie et qu'on parle plus tout à fait
du reste alors évidemment c'est dit on
passe vaccinale vous avez raison et à ce
nouvel incident à l'assemblée nationale
qui a repoussé son goût des quelques
heures d'un jour ou deux peut-être
l'adoption se passe vaccinale mais en
tout cas les médias en parlent et c'est
peut-être l'effet que recherchait le
président de la république au risque de
se mettre à dos une partie de la
population
le fait de stigmatiser les non vaccinés
on a entendu d'ailleurs les français
tout à l'heure ne veulent pas non plus
on pète pro vaccin mais pas non plus à
diaboliser les non vaccinés
vous avez tout à fait raison il alors
vous avez tout à fait raison et je
dirais que comme souvent et bien
emmanuel macron prend son risque vous
connaissez la formule prendre ce risque
ça veut dire savoir que un acte ou
savoir qu'une parole
vont va entraîner ou vont entraîner des
remous mais il le fait il ya un côté
chez emmanuel macron depuis son élection
de miss 7 il ya un côté joueurs de poker
tout de même parce que lorsqu'il se fait
élire il y a quasiment en cinq ans
personne ne le voyait venir il a pris
son risque il a d'une certaine manière
jouer un coup de poker il a bousculé
tous les clivages politiques à l'époque
et il a gagné et bien ce matin enfin
depuis hier soir je pense que c'est une
forme de deux coups de poker également
alors c'est un coup de poker maîtriser
quand même hein je le disais parce que
quand même dans ce pays en france on est
l'un des pays les plus vacciner au monde
on est un pays où les antilles vax
comolli représentent une minorité alors
il prend le risque effectivement vous
avez raison il prend le risque de
stigmatiser
cette minorité mais quand vous prenez le
risque de stigmatiser une minorité vous
ne touchez pas à la majorité et à votre
socle en clivant d'une certaine manière
comme le faisait nicolas sarkozy sur
l'autre thème comme au occupait à
l'agenda médiatique à notre nicolas
sarkozy en agissant ainsi en fait il il
fait de la politique d'une certaine
manière il solidifie évidemment son
socle et il crie vive un peu plus alors
ce qu'on pourra regretter quand même
c'est que il ya trois jours jean pierre
jean castex à l'assemblée nationale
après vous savez ce qu'on appelait le
coup du rideau c'est à dire c'est ces
députés qui viennent de manière
rapide le soir voter un texte et mettre
en minorité la majorité jean castex a
dit mais quand même on ne plaisante pas
avec
le pass vaccinale l'épidémie galope il
faut rassurer les français il faut
mettre en place
de quoi pouvoir conques contenir ce mur
deux mikron donc on ne joue pas avec la
vaccination d'une certaine manière c'est
makoun qui a répondu à jean castex parce
que lorsqu'ils emploient le mot
d'emmerdés pardonnez moi une fois de
plus de ne citer
et bien il en fait un jeu politique
emmanuel macron se placent vaccinale est
finalement bas il répond à jean castex
en utilisant les arguments de ceux qui
se sont amusés avec ce pass vaccinale
avec ce pass sanitaire transformée en
passe vaccinale on en est là on va voir
ce qui va se passer dans les jours qui
viennent on va voir les prochains
sondages peut-être que ça va les faire
bouger on verra bien eric revel une
dernière question il ya plus de doute
emmanuel macron avait envie d'en
d'emmerder les français mais a envie
aussi des d'y aller il l'a plus ou moins
confirmé aussi dans l'univers du lierre
absolument il le dit il le dit dans
l'interview il dit qu'il a qu'il a très
envie d'y aller qui qu'il a réfléchi
encore un petit peu car j'ai pu sa
formule en tête mais là il n'y a plus
beaucoup de suspense effectivement les
petites passivement
voilà il dit bon il est il est quasiment
candidat à sa propre réélection
alors il faut voir effectivement vous
avez raison les les sondages il est
toujours en tête de ces sondages avec ça
dépend des des études met tre 23 et 25
26% avec des des adversaires politiques
marine le pen
eric zemmour valérie pécresse qui sont
plutôt
à touche touche maintenant dans certains
sondages alors il faut savoir quand même
qu'un président sortant qui se déclarent
de nouveaux candidats mécaniquement en
tout cas c'est ce que nous ont montré
que nous a montrée l'histoire des
sondages mécaniquement hyper deux ou
trois points donc ça veut dire que
d'abord l'étiage du second tour sera
plus proche des 17 10 % que les 20% donc
bien malin qui pourrait dire
qui des trois candidats que je veux
c'est à l'heure va se retrouver au
second tour et puis emmanuel macron ne
va-t-il pas perdre deux trois points on
entre en campagne et dans ces cas là bas
vous voyez que l'ensemble du peloton se
regroupe ça sera l'élection de toutes
les surprises point d'interrogation moi
je me pose la question tous les jours et
je réponds par l'affirmative oui cette
élection présidentielle peut-être
l'élection toutes les surprises et on
verra cela merci beaucoup et eric revel
c'était l'édito politique de la matinale
ce matin